this is the darkest theory in mha and I
dare you to come up with a darker one
many people know the theory that Deku
was actually born with a quirk but that
Quirk was stolen by all for one and
ujiko and then ujiko tricked Deku into
thinking that he was born quirkless but
what kind of Quirk would baby Deku have
what if it was a very destructive Quirk
something like shigaraki's Decay or Ares
or wind and what if it manifested as
soon as he was born just like the
luminescent baby what if baby Deku
accidentally activated his Quirk and
killed his own father just like Arie did
deku's Mom then made a deal with all for
one to take deku's dangerous Quirk away
so he wouldn't hurt himself or anyone
else she didn't want to break deku's
Heart by telling him that he killed his
own father so she made up the story
about him working overseas see I told
you that